we have a break a short break we have
adam kalai who's a principal research
scientist at microsoft research new
england he's interested in machine
learning artificial intelligence and
algorithms
and lately has also been interested in
program synthesis teaching computers how
to program
he has he's won multiple best paper
awards a career award on alfred p sloan
fellowship he used to be on the faculty
at both georgia tech and tti chicago and
has chaired a number of
conferences
uh you know new england machine learning
day h comp 2017 colt 2010 et cetera um
actually one of my favorite papers from
adam was uh i guess i read it when i was
in grad school that's generating random
pre-factored numbers so this was done in
a phd thesis and it was
quite long and then adam had a nice
paper and soda that was
a page long and actually at some point
there's a little joke in there about um
you know see the following figure and it
was a smiley face
so okay so adam thank you great well
thank you so much
um did you hear me yeah so it's it's a
pleasure to be here i want to thank the
organizers of this event it's really uh
been wonderful all the talks have been
so talking about like deep results
summarizing a decade or more of
interesting research
my talk will be the opposite
okay
i'm going to be talking about some
recent stuff
and it's inspired by the problem of
could we understand what whales are
talking about what animals are
communicating um
ai now translates human languages very
well recent breakthroughs are making it
better and better could we understand
what whales are talking about and this
is coming from a question that came up
at at a at an event at the simons
institute um
and it's kind of interesting because
it's actually not not exactly a theory
workshop right it was called decoding
communication and non-human species it
was held in 2020 and one of the great
things about the simon institute events
is that um well they bridge theory and
practice so this event has inspired us
to work on a theory of uh of this
problem and it was a practical event and
all the uh uh
i didn't attend this but i attended it
virtually much later by watching all the
lectures that were excellent so it's
really been a great service in my
opinion and i know many people feel that
way and actually there's a big project
that arose from that called project seti
that is you know is it has been well
funded now and the idea is uh to
exactly to bring an interdisciplinary
team together including a bunch of
marine biologists and uh shafi is a
theory lead and and it's uh one of the
supporters is the simon institute so i
think this uh this project which is uh
has a lot of momentum uh owes a lot to
the simon's institute and shafi for for
starting it
um okay so but uh actually what i'm
gonna talk about today is a general
theory it's not specific to whales it
could be applied to other animals cows
or whatever so we'll we'll see how uh if
it makes sense and and what we can say
about what we might be able to translate
from animals so first let's just talk
about translation in general um as you
know you know i'm sure many of you use
google translate it works really well
and it works by starting with uh among
other things it starts with a data of
you know labeled data in one language
say french and and it's translation in
english and these are called parallel
data because you have a sentence and
then it's translation and the the
training data may be coming from some
distribution mu and it's labeled
according to some function well some
annotators f star and you get their
labels and uh one thing to important to
note about this is you all know that
there's more than one way to translate
things right you might say look out
there's a shark you might say there's a
shark look out watch out there's a shark
there's many different correct ways to
translate things but that's okay that's
not the biggest problem this works
pretty well as you all know in fact the
neural nets that they train on these
things can can learn the posterior they
can not only learn you know one
translation they can learn the
probability of distribution over all
translations right so um so don't be i
would say our focus is not on the fact
that there's multiple
possible translations that's a problem
even when you have parallel data
the computer can the neural nets can
handle that okay um and so this might
work for very simple animal languages so
there's a researcher named alexander
greene who studies cows and their
communication she spend months on the
fields recording the cows and she
believes that that i'm not joking the
cows have two kinds of moose a happy moo
and a sad moo
okay and she can tell by what the cow is
doing whether it's a happy moo and sad
moo and so she's created an annotated
corpus
and there's many ways to translate it
but she could use hooray and darn it or
whatever but anyway and so this um is
working and you can
you know i think soon we will be able to
detect from the sound of a cow uh
whether it's happy or sad so i think
this is feasible um and you can even do
it with labeled data is what i'm saying
she can label it you have a human
annotate the challenge when it gets to
an interesting animal like a sperm whale
is that we don't have any way to
translate their communication and the
biologists believe that they're
communicating in very interesting ways
the sperm whale they chose the sperm
whale for this project because it has
the largest brain of any animal it's six
times larger than the human brain and
there's all kinds of evidence i don't
want to get into it but that they're
communicating you can watch the videos
in the workshop if you want they're
really fascinating that their
communication is super rich and they're
communicating across miles and they have
really rich social structures and so
we're we're dying to know what they're
talking about right but we have no idea
we just don't know what to put in here i
mean you could have a biologist i guess
put in you know i think they're talking
about food here and i think they're
talking about diving there but then the
machine learning model would just learn
that same thing right it would just
start predicting i think they're talking
about food i think they're talking and
it wouldn't get into any of the rich
things they're talking about they really
strategize they need teamwork to defend
against whalers against and they develop
strategies and communicate them so
there's a lot of interesting things
we're dying to know what they're talking
about we have no way of getting this so
they're basically if we had a mermaid
who spoke uh who could understand the
whales at least and speaks english then
that mermaid could annotate some data
for us and that would probably be enough
even maybe a little bit of data would be
would be enough to get a lot of these
machine learning techniques to work but
we don't have a mermaid okay
as far as i know until we discover a
mermaid um but we do have neural nets
which may be able to learn both of these
languages and translate so that's kind
of the question um and just in case
you're wondering you know this
representation here you might have audio
files so in general the translation
could be from some binary data set to
another binary data set but or there's
actually been a bunch of people who've
already worked about on this and in the
simon's institute videos i watched one
uh they talk already about transcribing
you know how can we transcribe the audio
into some written form um this has been
studied a lot uh watched the videos
there's really interesting work on that
so let's just assume that we have a text
input for the whales and detect or
whatever animal and a text output but it
could also work from audio all right so
amazingly this problem has already been
studied
by applied machine learning people for
natural language even though we already
have plenty of aligned parallel data for
say english and french they said what if
we don't let's let's let's take a neural
net and train it on you know wonderland
trained on english and one trained on
french and let's see if we can get it to
translate
between these from piles of monolingual
corpus that you don't have any parallel
data just from a pile of english and
just from a pile of french and um the
answer is that it actually works so from
an implied uh point point of view
there's there's multiple papers by a
group at facebook and another group and
um it
it it spits out uh
you know grammatical english that
actually matches you can look and see
it's pretty good okay now there hasn't
been a ton of work on this because we
have parallel data it's not really as
useful but i think shafi's vision and
the vision of many people on that
project is hey maybe we can do something
similar with whales
right if we had a ton of data of whale
whales talking and
in fact they're collecting that data
they have microphones tagged on whales
and they have different strategies for
collecting
the whale data so
that's exactly what they're working on
similarly people did this for
programming languages they took data and
they trained it on python code and
separately on c plus plus code and
they're able to translate uh from python
to c plus plus and it looks really good
it captures the essence and sometimes
the code often the code even compiles
and gives exactly the same answer so
it's kind of amazing that that works
okay so that's inspiring um now in this
talk we're not gonna do the practice
we're gonna ask the sort of theory
question hey do we think this has a
chance because they're invest this was
fun and white as well but from for the
whales you know there's a lot of money
and work invested in this and collecting
all that data so you want to have a
sense does this have a chance of working
is there some what
what what
what do we think would this work at all
and what does it even mean to work so
we've talked about what unsupervised
machine translation is when you get this
two piles of monolingual data and i'm
going to talk oops about the information
theory an information theoretic model
where you have a prior over what you
think the whales are talking about
and an inefficient algorithm and then
i'll give kind of um i'm not going to
i'm going to make a toy model it's not
meant as a as a realistic model of
english but it's meant as a as a kind of
like a random graph models you have you
know where you want to understand the
behavior of algorithms and you see how
they scale the behavior as the language
gets more complicated or uh in a random
graphics or more nodes this will be a
toy example where it should work and
we'll see how the parameters relate to
each other how long sentences we need
and so on in order to translate um
so that's going to be our model and uh
and then after the theory i'll show you
a little bit about these language models
that we do have like gpt3 and things
like that i'll show you how they're how
you can use them in these very amazing
ways um okay so
uh so let me start with uh just
mentioning what is a language model a
language model is a distribution
uh if this is over english let's call it
new uh and remember we're translating
from x which is whalish to y which is
english we're going to make all our
assumptions on english we're not going
to make
very many assumptions on whalish at all
because we have no idea
all right so um
so our distribution is over
communications in english and uh nu is a
distribution it has some parameters
actually it's called them lambda and so
they choose these parameters it's not
important that you know this but i just
thought it might be interesting you take
a pile of english documents y y hat one
and so on y two and you wanna maximize
their likelihood the log likelihood
which is equivalent to minimizing the
sum of the negative log likelihoods of
all of the documents and the way they
train a language model this is useful to
know is they train it word by word
basically the job is to predict the next
word based on the previous words in the
document so you take the whole web and
you break it into words or even letters
or something in between and you just
train it and you try to predict the next
word and these things get really good at
predicting the next word okay so um much
better i think than a person and lately
i mean there's been advances month by
month newer and bigger language models
are coming out
so
now this sounds interesting you know you
can generate uh you can predict the next
word but if you can predict the next
word well that actually means you can
generate text from this distribution as
well so you can just generate word by
word uh and these things are efficient
and they do generate and you can so so
if they were trained on a pile of
brilliant research papers by
mathematicians like the people here then
that would mean they would have to
generate if they did their job well they
would have to generate the papers as if
they were written by mathematicians if
you started a paper they would have to
finish it so it's a very very hard
problem okay this this language modeling
and these neural nets have hundreds of
billions of parameters as i'll talk
about and they're doing pretty well at
this and they're getting better and
better it's kind of scary
okay so let me talk uh before i get into
those language models because that's not
really the focus let me talk about the
translation problem in our information
theoretic model for the unsupervised
translation problem so we have we're
going to define a loss function here and
this loss is kind of going to capture
our ability to predict
okay at the translations so we have
three ingredients to the loss first we
have a translator which is a function
that maps whalish to english i'm using
whalish as an example it could be an
animal
um then we have uh so that's and it's
we're gonna assume for this talk that
it's one to one so that given the
translation you could go backwards and
figure it out um
uh just just for simplicity uh
we also have a distribution that we're
going to assume the neural we've learned
really well let's say you know if we've
trained this thing it's not obvious but
it learned english just from reading the
whole web maybe if we give it enough
whalish data it'll learn whalish and
it'll pass the whalish touring test
it'll have conversations with the whales
that's all great but we won't know what
it's saying so the question is how are
we going to do that um so okay so that's
but we have this let's assume we have
this great model for whalish mu and we
have this great uh we're going to have a
probability distribution over english
now um it's not going to be well
actually it's specifically going to be
over what we think the english
translations of walish would look like
it's not all
we could put you know gbt3 here but gpt3
knows all the languages in the world and
it could it would just start translating
maybe to other languages and to think
monkeys and stuff so um
i'll talk more about this later but just
suspend your disbelief and assume that
we have as input
a great distribution over whalish and a
good prior not perfect but a prior over
what we think
that the whales might be talking about
but in terms of their its translation to
english so if we had a mermaid
who really knew
uh english and whalish maybe the mermaid
maybe every not everything can be
translated perfectly but whatever the
mermaid would translate however whatever
we think that the mermaid would
translate we have a prior what do we
think the way what do we think the
mermaid would be writing down that we
think the whales are talking about okay
and so um the loss is going to be the uh
is going to be something that looks like
cross entropy here so
we have the the our prior here and we
have the distribution over what we would
get if we translated the whaleish
the whaleish messages by this function f
so we want to say is a function good or
is a function bad if we have two
functions and we look at their
translation and one of them translates a
whalish thing and says feet my simon
harmonica that doesn't make any sense
and the other one translates it to
something that we kind of think whales
might be talking about like
you need to dive really deep for a squid
now okay well obviously the second one
is it looks a little better than the
first one so you know a human looking at
a bunch of translations could we say
which one we think is the right one and
if we can do that then maybe
uh our prior a gpt3 or whatever this
neural net can do the same thing because
it's got a great prior over english so
it assigns probabilities we ascend so
maybe it's going to be
able to solve this problem so what's a
good prior well we want something that
when we translate the documents so we
take so we take a doc we take a whalish
message and we translate it by f okay
and then we get so this is the
distribution of the probability
distribution of translations that's rho
hat our approximation that should look
like rho these two things should be
similar take whalish things translate it
by f if f is a good translator it should
kind of match what our prior is that
doesn't have to be perfect but it should
match it and you could use other this is
some way of measuring uh this difference
distance but you could use a statistical
distance or something else but this one
i think is very convenient
it's well suited for language models
because it says look whatever we
translate if we translate if we take a
whalish message translated by this f
our
prior shouldn't assign zero probability
to it shouldn't be something ridiculous
that we think whales would never say
that so that's that's uh that's the idea
okay and um
okay so this is very similar to
cross-entropy
just to take off my shirt we're doing
getting to the math so um
and uh there's a few nice properties
about this uh this loss one is that you
can break it up word by word so another
equivalent way to think of it is if you
took all the translations according to
your translator and you said okay here
are the translations how good would it
be at predicting the next word of the
translation so if we said you need to
to dive really you know our language
model would predict a high probability
on the word deep so it'd be good it'd be
accurate at its predictions of what's
being translated that's one way to think
about it and another way i'll just
mention which is equivalent is um
you could think about the dissimilarity
between the probability distributions
over the actual whalish
and
if you took uh if you took a tran if you
took something from our prior and you
translate it backwards to walish you
have this that's why we're assuming that
the function's invertible just just
mention this is a dual interpretation
we're not going to use it but it's
equivalent it's nice to know that you
could also look at the dissimilarity in
terms of whalish
what whalish you get and if you took our
prior and back translated it to whalish
how similar would those distributions be
okay and that's easier to write
mathematically but i think the first one
is a bit easier to think about because
um this is we're actually looking at
english translations and are prior so we
can make we can make assumptions about
english we're going to make some strong
assumptions but at least they're about
english we're not going to make much
assumption at all about whalish so
that's that's better and in future work
you could try to make weaker assumptions
we can think about that
okay um so this also suggests an
inefficient algorithm in this talk i'm
not going to talk about efficient
algorithms practitioners have algorithms
but what would the inefficient algorithm
be well if there's some family of
parameters for your models you want to
minimize your loss
this loss here okay and now it's
important that we assume that there's
some bounded models this family the size
of this parameter space is going to be
important if we allowed ourselves to use
any translation
does anyone know what the best
translation would be if we if we didn't
restrict our translators we said okay we
have our prior
over english translations and then we
know the whalish distribution perfectly
what would be the
optimal way to translate according to
this loss
no oh that's an interesting idea you
could ignore the input and output but
we're assuming we have a one-to-one
deterministic translator
um right
what is it
yes you you take the most likely you
could the thing that would maximize this
is you take the most likely whalish
sense and you translate it to the thing
that's most likely under your prior and
the second most likely
which is a ridiculous uh translation it
won't actually you translate the second
most likely whalish thing to the second
most likely english thing and that
probably won't give you a very
meaningful
translation and if you see what i mean
it would be the most likely sentence
corresponds to the most like an english
sentence in the second most way likely
that's not a good translator we need to
assume that there's a small translator
and so
let me give you some intuition for this
it's much easier to translate than it is
to generate think about writing a paper
with proofs and everything versus
translating a paper
right if you just had to translate a
paper you don't really need to know math
that well you don't need to know how to
solve problems you need to know generate
you need a huge language model and
that's why these language models are
huge they have tons of parameters think
about any word the word shark think
about how much you know about sharks you
know that sharks have sharp teeth you
know what they eat you know where they
live all these you know
ton dozens of facts about sharks just
from the word shark and and uh both the
whaleish language model and the english
language model need to know that but in
order to translate you kind of just need
to know how to say shark in both
representations you also need to know
the grammar
but um the reason that these language
models have you know billions or
trillions of parameters now is that they
they need to know so many facts about
the world too it's not a language model
is kind of a misnomer it really needs to
know how to prove theorems well not the
whalish one but it needs to know you
know facts about the world that when you
go there's a lot in common we have with
wales we all know that you know if you
go down then you have to come up we know
all kinds of interesting facts about the
world that we have in common with the
whales and so these both language models
would share that and the translator
we're going to restrict the size of the
translator to be much smaller
okay
is that clear
all right so
so here's our toy model and again this
is not meant as a realistic model of
english but at least we're making
assumptions about english and not about
whalish
and it's sort of a it's a sort of an
easy case where it would be easy to
translate and we're just making sure
that it would be information
theoretically possible and see how much
information we would have and again
remember the issue we're not focused on
is the multiple possible translations
there's many ways to word something in
english that are all roughly equivalent
that's that's not the crux of the
problem the crux of the problem is that
we don't have any label data okay so
what is our model going to be we're
going to start with a a very simple
model of english where we have a tree so
the first word is going to be one of
some
fixed number of possibilities like we're
thinking of the set of first of all
we're thinking of a set of plausible
english translations of what the whales
are saying should be grammatical
sentences that kind of make sense okay
but it could be we could have a very
broad perspective so the first word
could be ocean
and the second word could be waves and
the third word could be break that's a
sentence i'm just giving very short
sentences the first word could be sharks
the second word could be swim the third
one could be fast so all the paths here
um the setup has here determine a set of
plausible translations okay in any set
of
sentences or words of let's say uh and
any any let's say assume that there's k
choices for the first word and k choices
for the second word and so on you could
relax this assumption but i'm just
making a simple model so that's this
this one we should hopefully we'll be
able to translate
and the length is the depth of the tree
here so there's n words let's assume and
we're very curious about how many words
we need in order to translate well
so there's k to the end possible
plausible sentences in our model and the
strong assumption we're making here
which is kind of ridiculous but it's
still we should be able to translate in
this case is that the words on these
edges are all random so we've got a set
of random uh plausible
uh translations and this again is sort
of like an erdish reni uh referential
attachment random graph thing you know
if we have if if the set we have a some
set of plausible things any set of
plausible translations can be organized
in a tree where you just branch on the
first word and then um we are going to
assume though that those are random okay
the words on these things are random and
this determines a set of plausible
things that the whales might be talking
about so we assume we have some set of
plausible things it's random okay um and
then um so these are the plausible
translations it's a subset of uh english
and english is a subset of words to the
end just for some set of words and you
have n words
um and so one's one assumption we need
to make is that the branching factor is
less than the number of words over four
which is a very mild assumption the
number of words in english is like a
hundred thousand the number of plausible
words at any point is what's called the
perplexity of a language and that's
around 20. so it's way less okay i don't
think that's our biggest assumption um
and then the the other thing is the uh
we're going to assume that the real
translations what the whales are
actually talking about is only some
subtree instead of using all k of these
options maybe they're talking about some
little k options each time so k little k
in this example is 2 so you have three
possible you're you you're open-minded
and you think whales are maybe asking
questions like do whales they dream um
but in fact whales never ask a question
there's no way that they would ask that
first word do so there's some subtree
and they're talking in the subtree
basically a language model encodes all
kinds of information about the world and
the way we're describing what it encodes
about the world is through a set of
plausible english sentences because
meaning is very hard to represent okay
so this is the assumption that the words
on the this tree are random and that the
subtree that the whales are talking on
is also uh random which which little k
out of the k things it is little k
obviously has to be less than or equal
to big k if it's equal to big k life is
great our
our set of plausible things that the
whales might be talking about is all is
exactly what they're talking about
that's great um but it might be smaller
and so this model will just denote
that's the only notation we have is this
random language tree okay model okay
but if we have a random language tree we
will be able hopefully we'll be able to
translate so here's the theorem so we
have some family of uh parameters space
for our neural nets let's say and we're
for simplicity let's just assume that
these uh two the sizes of the
uh languages are the same you could get
that by padding and then the theorem
says with high probability over the
random choice of
uh language for the random choice of
plausible
things that we might be talking about p
that we think they might be talking
about p and the things that the mermaid
would translate them to are
uh if there's some good translator in
our model so we're assuming that there
is some good um
parameter in our model some good neural
net which has not too many parameters
then uh and by the way just that low
parameter assumption could uh one way to
make that is that there's some sentence
by sentence translator that would
restrict the number of translations so
if there's some good translator if
there's no good translator we're in
trouble anyway then we're going to have
low error and error is defined to be the
probability that if we take a new
whalish sentence our estimated
parameters theta hat will give a
different answer than the mermaid would
okay
again in this random model there
shouldn't be too many translations that
there should be just one translation for
each thing but we're going to look at
our error and so uh what is this theta
hat theta hat is the thing that
minimizes the loss
we're assuming first let's assume that
the distribution over the plausible
senses in our prior is uniform and that
the distribution over what the whales
are talking about
they're actually talking about is
uniform over the back translations
so this is where we're not making any
assumption on the whales we're just
assuming uh that that they're that their
translations look a certain way in
english
uh it's also uniform over the subtree of
wales
and then the bound we get here let's
unpack that there's a number of
translator parameters
here and then k little k to the n is
like the number of whalish
messages or something it grows
exponentially with the length so an is
kind of like a capturing the complexity
of the language the longer the language
the longer the sentences that we're
translating
if if n is large it means that each word
is it has some end new option has some
new k new options
based on the previous n minus one word
so that would not work for cows but uh
the for more complex language it makes
sense that the each word uh has some
options that depend that are affected by
the previous and minus one words
um so so we are kind of getting what we
expected which is that that uh as long
as the language is as long as the
translators is much easier as long as
translation is much easier than uh
modeling the language
we will be able to to translate um we
can we can weaken these assumptions to
just that the support of rho is actually
the plausible things and that the
support of mu is is somewhere over the
set of whales translations and we
replace this one over k to the n by the
maximum of the probability distribution
i'm really low on time so let me just
give you some cool examples of the
language model so just to show you
language models you can give them a
prefix and again they they predict the
next word so they'll generate from this
prefix so i gave it a prefix let's see
what it does so i said here's what sam
and eat and can you tell me what i think
you think sperm whales eat and it just
generated all this and then it picks
some more animals so it really knows a
lot about what what animals are eating
it's not uh and this is from a gpt3
which has 175 billion parameters so we
just gave it a prefix and it generates
word by word and it you can check it out
it's pretty pretty accurate um
they can learn from a single example so
you can give them some cute example here
i took a sentence and i just decided
let's put mu between each word that's
not something i think they'll find on
the web and boom you know from one
example they learn so language models
are learners too because that happens on
a web page
they can write your papers for you you
can just do
write something and they will complete
it and
it's actually quite accurate i mean i i
went and checked this this is a
reference this is an actual paper about
whales do sleep half of their brain at a
time it's amazing um
uh they can explain jokes and so the way
you do that is you they some this is all
human written they give two examples of
jokes and their explanations and then
they said do you see that google just
hired an eloquent whale for their tpu
team now many of you may not get that
joke but gpt3 will explain it to you
i'm not joking the explanation is that
tpus are a type of computer chip that
google uses for deep learning a pod is a
group of tpus a pod is also a group of
whales the joke is that the whale is
able to communicate between the two
groups of whales but the speaker is
pretending that the whale is able to
communicate between groups it's so it's
perfect it's a great explanation
understanding jokes is like the
hardest thing of understanding language
so these language models are really
working they can write code
um
they have a prior this is what i want to
say last thing i'll say sorry is that
they have a prior or you know i talked
about having a prior over what we think
the whales are talking about here's a
one way to get a prior you put in a
little prefix and you say here's what i
think two whales are talking about and
gpt-3 has
you know posterior over what it it
thinks two p two whales will talk about
and it starts generating conversations
and it'll have positive probability on
any conversation but much more likely on
conversations that are about krill and
things that whales do so this is real
gpt3 i just did this you know uh
recently and it's generating what it
does so um okay so i i guess uh i will
just go to my conclusions
uh
so in conclusion uh we have an
information theoretic model it suggests
that if the conversation if the language
is rich enough and the translator is
simple enough we will hopefully be able
to translate what's missing is um this
model
random models don't have any symmetries
and real language has a couple
symmetries like north and south it may
be very hard for us to translate if we
hear them talking about if they had
directions like north and south and we
hear them talking about it we might get
that flipped there are certain
symmetries that are present in language
which the random model didn't capture
um we have a lossy model as well that i
didn't talk about and the other thing
that i really think would be amazing is
for really good translation you actually
want a background so there's a lot of
things whales have some sort of social
structure that we're unaware of and
maybe they play games
you know that they that they have that
we don't know anything about and if you
translate it we won't understand so a
great translation would have some kind
of background book little you know
section that you would read that would
explain the whole whale
you know social structure and then you
would read the translations after that
and they would make sense and in
principle information theoretically the
computer should be able to generate that
as well as part of the translation
process um
okay we're not talking about the fishing
donald so thank you very much
um
sean
uh
so how much like in the the
uh the example of
translating c to python or english to
french
how much uh do you think it's utilizing
the uh like the character as being
english uh and english is a romance well
it can translate between uh like um
mandarin chinese and english it doesn't
do as well but it's still made by an
experiment
you can do like they've done parallel uh
mandarin
mandarin english translations still it's
still reasonable yeah so i mean if we
could get that kind of translation with
uh whales that would be amazing plus if
the whales are swimming with their
newborns this project they plan to kind
of uh track mothers and their babies
imagine that if the mothers are
explaining to the babies like we're
getting a whole dictionary if they're
teaching their kids how to speak and we
can translate some of it correctly we
may actually be able to learn the whole
thing so it's really exciting
good question
hey adam so one question it is
conceivable that just like people living
in different parts of the world also
whales living in different oceans they
speak different languages yes and
translating between different in
languages even without knowing what it
means is something that could be easier
right
friends
they are talking about the same things
yeah you're saying we could we could
help the whales by translating between
different whale languages
yeah yeah
it might blow their mind that's true
that would be very likely to work i
think um there is evidence that the
whales have different dialects i mean
they know that the biologists have
studied that and they and they have
tried to put they know that different
groups of whales with different dialects
do not like talking to each other we
don't know if it's because
they don't understand each other or just
because they're not interested
it's a good question
we are running a bit late so i think i'm
around if you want to ask the question
maybe at this point we can take a
shorter break than planned uh maybe till
let's say 3 35 sound reasonable so 3 35.